what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today we have some huge news about
the case of Jonathan Majors Jonathan
Majors is currently in court defending
himself against alleged assault charges
most people know by now but if you're
not aware Jonathan Majors the Marvel
star who plays King the Conqueror in the
MCU who also starred in Creed 3 was
arrested a couple of months ago on
charges of assault his ex-girlfriend is
the one who is pressing the charges
against him claiming that he lacerated
her right ear and broke her right finger
Tuesday June 20th Jonathan Majors
appeared in court for the very first
time where the judge set an official
trial date for August 3rd where he is
prepared to provide evidence to prove
that he is innocent and we have a lot of
new evidence that has come out today and
this is released by his official team
his lawyer released the evidence to
insider.com giving them the exclusive on
this and this does include video footage
and like I've mentioned the reason we
are covering this because this will
directly affect the MCU if Jonathan
Majors is found guilty Marvel Studios
will drop him as king the Conqueror and
they will have to recast him and we've
remained neutral while covering this
news however I do have to say this
evidence that is released today and the
time stamps on everything that
supposedly happened does seemingly
support the fact that Jonathan Majors is
innocent now of course we can't say
anything for sure but we will go over
everything that was provided to Insider
which they have posted an exclusive
article on that really describes in
detail all of the evidence and the
events that took place and when they
took place and why this isn't Jonathan
majors's favor so hopefully if this does
turn out to be true and Jonathan Majors
is innocent he can stay Kang the
Conqueror in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe because I personally think he
did an amazing job as king and of course
I really hope that he didn't assault
this woman so let's break it all down
and if you want to stay up to date on
everything in the MCU be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
we're also doing a giveaway we'll talk
more about that at the end so as I
mentioned this Insider article is
extremely detailed and I don't want to
miss anything so we're going to go
through the entire thing it starts by
claiming that on June 20th he did go to
court he didn't really say anything
besides good morning to the judge his
lawyer Priya Chaudhary told Insider that
they had hoped that the misdemeanor
assault charges would be dropped by the
Manhattan prosecutors because of the
evidence that they provided so far that
did not happen and they set a court date
for August 3rd but Majors lawyer spoke
up and said that he was still very eager
to prove his innocence to a jury so
Majors was arrested on suspicion of
hitting his then girlfriend now
ex-girlfriend Grace Jabari in a fight on
a Chinatown Street Corner his lawyer
wrote a letter to the criminal court
stating mrabari claims that Mr Majors
assaulted her in a car in Chinatown
around 12 a.m on March 25th 2023 and
during this incident Mr Majors broke her
finger and lacerated her ear she goes on
the stage we have proof that this is a
complete lie she says that they have
defense eyewitness interviews phone
records credit card statements and hours
of surveillance and police body camera
video and that is a lot that really is a
lot of evidence to have in favor of
Jonathan majors and as I mentioned we do
have video footage of some of this
evidence that we'll talk about in just a
bit the article goes on to state that
Major's lawyer chaudry alleged in the
letter that this evidence suggested that
Jabari injured herself some seven hours
after that midnight fight when Jabari
took a fall while alone in majors's
Penthouse apartment after drinking and
taking sleeping pills now Insider does
state that the evidence that was shown
with Insider which wasn't the entirety
of the evidence did not show how Jabari
was injured or didn't show the entirety
of the fight between majors and Jabari
however it did show that jabari's ear
and finger were unin injured right after
the fight for several hours meaning that
when people saw her immediately after
the fight and there is footage of this
she was not injured at all which is
evidence supporting that Jonathan Majors
did not assault her and here's where it
gets really interesting chaudry and
Major's team turned in video evidence to
the court this comes from police body
worn camera footage that was turned in
and it shows Jabari in majors's
apartment saying I don't know 19 times
when asked by arriving Medics and cops
how she was injured so when the cops
arrived and the Medics arrived they
asked her how did you get hurt and she
said 19 times I don't know then chaudry
says in her letter that the NYPD footage
showed the lead officer coaching Miss
Jabari to accuse Mr majors of assault
she said in the letter that the arrest
was racist and showed the officers
questioning among themselves how Majors
who they didn't recognize as a famous
actor could afford to live in a luxury
Penthouse chaudry then stated even
though Miss Jabari admitted to drinking
to the point of throwing up taking
sleeping pills and having no idea how
she woke up in a closet with a cut on
her head and injured finger the police
jumped to the conclusion that Mr Majors
must have done this to miss Jabari and
here's the thing they have video
evidence of this from the police body
cams that they have submitted to the
court already so they have seen this
this is why they thought that they would
dismiss this case altogether because
Jabari literally said I don't know many
many times when asked how she got hurt
and it shows the police kind of coaching
her to say that it was Mr Majors this is
pretty damning evidence and really does
support Jonathan Majors now we have more
evidence but I do want to talk about
what chaudry has said about Jonathan
Majors she said that he wants this to go
to trial yesterday meaning he has wanted
this to happen already he wants to go to
trial he wants to show the evidence
since he wants to speak and he wants to
prove himself innocent she says that he
is heartbroken as he watches his career
dangle in the wind and it really is
heartbreaking if he is innocent and
let's talk about the other evidence that
was supplied and let's also talk about
the eyewitnesses that they have the
alleged assault supposedly took place in
a car as majors and Jabari were being
driven somewhere and they state that
this was not a direct employee of
Jonathan Majors but instead worked for a
company called black Lane and upscale
private black car company chaudry
Major's lawyer said that this driver is
prepared to testify in court on majors's
behalf that Majors never raised his
voice or a hand against Jabari as they
argued inside his car or after he pulled
the car over and the dispute Spilled Out
onto a busy street corner chaudry said
the driver of the car saw and heard
everything and now he is prepared to
testify to make it even more interesting
there is Street surveillance video that
was viewed by Insider and they state
that you can see Jonathan Majors trying
to flee from Jabari as she pulls him out
of the car and they State he is a big
guy and she's pulling him so hard that
she pulls his body into the car as he's
trying to run away and they say and you
see the coat rip and he does finally get
out so Majors after getting into this
argument in the car where the driver
says he never reads his voice or lifted
a hand against her is trying to get out
of the car he told the driver to stop
and he's trying to get away from her but
she is literally pulling him back into
the car to the point to where the Street
surveillance video shows him being
pulled back into the car and shows his
coat being ripped until he finally does
get away and to top it all off what's
kind of funny is that a small group of
women who witnessed the fight recognized
Jonathan majors and the woman jumps on
him hugs him and asks for a selfie and
he's so nice and they take a selfie this
is what his lawyer said and this was
caught by the Street surveillance
footage also the footage reviewed by
Insider showed Jabari using both of her
hands to briskly fiddle with her hair
the lawyer said she ties her hair into a
knot if your finger was broken and you
went to tie your hair into a knot it
would hurt she continued to say she
gathered her hair behind her ear if your
ear was cut and your finger was broken
and you want to do that you would be
like oh what happened but she's totally
fine speaking of the surveillance
footage and here's the real kicker
here's where we dive into the
surveillance footage after this the two
separated Majors went to an upper east
side hotel and Jabari went to a
nightclub called Lucy's which is spelled
l-o-o-s-i-e apostrophe s and phone
records show that Jonathan Majors not
too long after he went to the hotel sent
her a breakup text before turning off
his phone but perhaps the most important
part of all of this is the footage
obtained by Jonathan Major's team of
Jabari in that nightclub minutes after
the fight took place and four hour she
stays there with no apparent signs of
being hurt whatsoever in fact the
footage shows her using her right hand
many many times walking up the stairs as
we can see here and then in some other
footage as you can see here she goes up
to the DJ and he grabs her by the hand
and she has no signs of being hurt so
video footage shows her completely fine
partying immediately after this alleged
assault and then to top it all off there
is another witness because eventually
Majors did go home to his Penthouse
apartment and apparently one of the
doors inside his apartment was locked so
he called the handyman to open the
bedroom door once he came in and opened
the door majors and the handyman found
Jabari half naked and passed out on the
floor of a walk-in closet and the
handyman is prepared to testify that
this actually happened in court and
Majors is the one who actually called
9-1-1 at this point in time in which he
was then arrested also they say that
police body camera surveillance footage
does show when Jabari is alone with one
officer her looking down at her hand
going what happened to my finger showing
that that was the first time that she
actually noticed her finger was hurt and
this was after they had already taken
Majors away so this is all pretty
damning evidence that Jonathan Majors is
innocent of course we have to wait till
the official court rolling but we do see
the video surveillance here of Jabari
seemingly being fine and uninjured and
all of the evidence that they have said
they have submitted to the court that is
a lot in Jonathan Major's favor plus not
to mention several witnesses that he has
are ready to testify on his behalf
including the driver who said that
Jonathan Majors never raised a hand or
even his voice and according to the
victim the assault happened in the car
and the driver can testify no it didn't
plus the video footage of him trying to
leave the car her trying to pull him
back in and then him eventually walking
away so hopefully this is good news
hopefully he really is innocent and this
evidence does prove that in court and
hopefully he can continue to play King
the Conqueror in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and his career can get back on
track but of course if we hear anything
else we'll be sure to let you know so
don't forget to like this video
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest news also don't forget to leave a
comment this will enter you in our
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox
series X A PS5 so Marvel Legends items
and some DC items as well don't forget
to follow us on Instagram and Twitter
and check out our patreon if you want to
further support the channel as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
foreign